las vegas we have our own very expensive  stadium it is a legion stadium and it  was almost entirely empty this football  season  the pandemic kept raiders and unlv rebel  fans away  losing sports and spectators also means  lost revenue  analysts believe the valley lost about  two billion dollars from the impact of  lost sports  while fans have not been allowed inside  the stadium still has the bills to pay  analysts believe getting people back in  the stadium  will be a sign of broader recovery i  don't think there's going to be any  greater sign  of las vegas resurgence than a allegiant  stadium  filled with 65 screaming raiders fans  that's broadcast to 60 million people  all over the united states and many ways  all over the world  showing that las vegas is opening of  course it's not just football to other  events as well garth brooks was supposed  to be the first big act at the stadium  right now his show has been pushed to  february